I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense how long after you had this
unfortunate job that you didn't love
driving trucks and being a bouncer did
you break your wrist so after that I
played arena football I broke my wrist
in the second game my rookie season and
then I played 14 more games with a
broken wrist yeah
so they x-rayed it the doctor was like
here's the break Wow and I go I think as
athletes we're just kind of stupid we're
like well can i play on it you know a
weakness it's not something you're
supposed to show no physical or mental
and if I told the coaches they would cut
me because I'm arena football is very
cutthroat they don't you don't give the
whole season they're bringing guys in
every week and wow it's a great new
players in who are fresh every week to
practice against you it sucks okay
you're the only making a couple hundred
bustles so what I'm getting at is that
interestingly enough he kind of weren't
happy we're playing football well I
don't know you were doing a job you
didn't like you're doing a couple jobs
he didn't like yeah it was super
cutthroat but it was painful but I had a
bigger dream in mine which is make the
NFL okay so I was like I'm willing to
stick this out for the bigger dream but
you had to be done right you couldn't
play after that so I played this season
and then I got I had a surgery I thought
I was gonna take like six weeks it took
six months to so that was over with for
football then dinner was over I was in
denial for a year so there's nothing to
come back but my arm didn't have any
strength about a year and a half yeah I
would think so then I started doing I
was on my sister's couch and for a year
and a half of my sister's couch making
no money
feeling like a loser and just depressed
I said what I'm gonna do with my life my
dream is over what do I do now and
that's when I started seeking out
mentors my ID actually my dad got a
really bad accident right then as well
where he was kind of my backup plan he
had a life insurance company he was like
when you're done living a dream you can
always come work for me so I kind of had
that in mind like I wasn't gonna have to
go find something if I really needed it
he would take care of me he got a bad
accident car accident was in a coma for
three months still allowed today but
he's never been the same you don't when
they have an emotional connection with
him and I was like wow my dad's not here
to support me
I didn't have a college degree yet
because I left early for the NFL Combine
stuff and trainings and I really had no
skills because I had to cheat all
through your school all through
elementary school high school college
like I cheated my way through okay
so then once so I was like how am I
gonna do anything and who's gonna pay me
for anything is this when you came up
with the handball vision it is so I was
on my sister's couch 2008 Olympics China
I just got the cast off maybe like a
couple months before and I'm on the
couch watching the Olympics because for
me the Olympus is always the ultimate
goals an athlete that I've always wanted
to do but I was never playing a sport
that was actually in the Olympics right
I was I was playing football and I was
playing basketball but I wasn't good
enough to play basketball in lippies and
I saw this and late a night like 2:00 or
3:00 a.m. they were showing like the
sports that no one cares about in the
USA and they showed this board called
team handball and I was like where has
this been my whole life
like this is my sports it was
unbelievable 40 million people play this
around the world how is it played it's
like water polo on a basketball court
this was opposed to water your dribbling
you're passing the ball you're shooting
it behind a net there's like a goalie
imagine like soccer with your hands at
the basketball court
it's super fast it's extremely physical
and there's a lot of athletic power and
speed and accuracy yeah and I was just
like this is my sport and I just became
obsessed I just had this vision in my
mind I was like I can make the Olympics
through this because I can make the USA
team I don't even know if the US had a
team I was just I'm going to make this
team it's not a move in France exactly
and I started researching right then
like us a handball teams
there's no professional league in the
USA but there's amateur club teams and
there was a team in New York that was
like the three-time national champions
and I said I'm gonna move to New York
when I make money I'm gonna go learn the
sport I'm gonna make the USA national
team I'm gonna go play the Olympics I'm
gonna fulfill my childhood dream
and a year and a half later I started
making enough money when I moved to New
York City I couldn't get a hold of
anyone on any of these club teams no one
would respond to me to email nothing but
they had a website where their practice
schedule was in New York and so I just
said I'm gonna show up and just go there
one of these nights I show up on the
only American there it's all Europeans
who played professionally in Europe
who've now moved to New York because
that's where the game is harder than you
guys exactly and I said my name's Lewis
Howes I'm here to make the USA team go
to the Olympics and they just laughed at
me they're all talking like different
languages the laughing they're asked of
me and I said watch me and they're like
well this is our last practice of the
season
oh we just won the national
championships a week ago we're just here
to like hang out and kind of connect
come back in two months I said all right
tell me one show up two months later and
I'm practicing twice a week cuz they
went to two-week press a week twice a
week the next nine months I make the USA
national team and play an international
competition for the last seven years and
they just played in a pan on games but
you've gotta win the pan of games to go
the Olympics and then a win so that's
the challenge if the Olympics is in the
USA then we'd been automatic qualifier
but it's not gonna be there until 2028
and I'll be 44 so my 43 so we'll see
keep working at it it's been an amazing
journey like it for me I'm okay if it
doesn't actually happen do you still
play right now
I just played three weeks ago in Brazil
with the team yeah yeah I'm one of the
oldest guys on the team at 36 and it's
kind of like everyone's like 22 who
plays in sport you know 20 to 20 so I
was just in Brazil playing against the
Brazilian national team and they're like
town in the world
yeah wow that's impressive and it's just
and I'm okay again if I don't achieve
the dream now but for me it's like how
did you get to that point I wasn't at
that point until a couple years ago
where I was just like it's gonna be okay
on any dream I have I'm now okay if it
actually doesn't happen on one because
there's only so much I can control so as
long as I know I did everything in my
power to do everything I could to make
it happen yeah
like the team has to be amazing there's
only one tournament every four years you
have to win to qualify yeah
there's things out of my control it's
tough yeah and but I am okay with
anything in my life knowing that I gave
everything to pursue the dream in my
power and I lay it all on the field like
if I do that and it doesn't work out
then I can rest in peace and be like you
know I have no regrets so that's where
I'm at right now like any big dream I
have it's okay if I don't achieve it
anymore I want to
you